let's talk about the EPA right we know
based on the report that the EPA put out
I guess a week week and a half ago that
their new plan that's supposed to
replace the Obama administration's clean
power rule their plan is actually going
to kill as many as 1,400 American
citizens every single year the EPA
admitted that they admitted that their
own plan that is going to kind of roll
back some of the regulations on the coal
industry and coal-fired power plants
it's gonna kill 1,400 people a year at
most at most and maybe as few as 500
right but really as the EPA says isn't
that a small price to pay so that these
coal companies don't have to spend money
to work on things like carbon capture
they don't have to worry about where to
dump their toxic coal ash they can just
dump it in those ponds that then go on
to poison rivers and aquifers and
everything it touches that's what
they're telling us they're telling us
that this cost 1,400 possible American
lives lost each year most of which are
due to the increased particulates that
will be going into the atmosphere it's
worth it because we don't want the dying
coal industry to have to pay a few more
dollars each year to clean up their
messes no so let's let them pollute the
air and the water and the land and the
people because 1,400 deaths a year is
totally cool with this incarnation of
the EPA the Environmental Protection
Agency as it stands right now does not
work for the public health it does not
work for environmental health it 100%
works for corporations that's it that is
who this EPA now under the at least
temporary direction of andrew wheeler
the former coal lobbyist they are
working for corporations they did the
same thing under Scott Pruett the only
reason Pruitt in that
leaving offices because his scandalous
history got a little too much for him to
overcome he wasn't even fired he just
chose to resign because he couldn't even
go have a meal in peace but this
administration this EPA I mean heck the
Department of Education the Department
of Justice the Department of Commerce
every piece of this administration is
100% working for the benefit of major
corporations and in the case of the EPA
it's the fossil fuel industry it's the
chemical industries your Dow DuPont your
Bayer Monsanto's out there poisoning
everything that we hold dear our bodies
our property the water everything and
the EPA isn't doing a thing about it
enforcement actions at the EPA since
Donald Trump took office have fallen by
94% 94% the EPA doesn't care they don't
care if their own policies are going to
poison you they don't care if their
policies are gonna send you to an early
grave maybe you'll be lucky enough to
where you're not one of the 1,400 people
that dies in the next year but maybe
they get you the next one
or the one after that and if they don't
kill you they also admit that it's going
to increase the instances of asthma and
chronic bronchitis as well as other
upper respiratory diseases so they may
not put you in the grave but they're
gonna make it to where you have trouble
breathing for the rest of your life and
again they're only doing it so that the
coal industry doesn't have to spend more
money to have a slightly cleaner
operation the only solution only this is
it this is the only thing we can do is
get off fossil fuels at a time when
every other developed country in the
world is trying to switch to renewable
energy doing their best trying to cut
back fossil fuel cut out coal completely
we're doubling down on it
we're deregulating them
Donald Trump is out there promising that
their coal jobs are coming back even
when the coal miners come and do
interviews that interviews afterwards
and say yeah our jobs aren't coming back
we know that why is he lying to us that
actually happened in the last week but
nonetheless he's out there making these
lofty promises that coal somehow is
gonna come back perhaps in the same way
that this mad man in Oval Office
actually is bringing back asbestos into
our daily lives unfortunately that's a
topic for another day and that is all
the time we have for today I appreciate
Dave and let me sit and today I will be
back tomorrow David will still be on
vacation
you can find me on Twitter at fair and
balanced Farr o n ba la in ced that also
happens to me how you can find me on
both facebook and instagram see you next
time